then we had the problems of the new
variant which i'll come on to in the
next slide
and uh the worst period of winter
combining
to lead to a significant increase since
that
time and we're now into a situation
where across the country as a whole
roughly one in 50 people
have got the virus higher in some parts
of the country
lower in others but 1 in 50 is really
quite a
very large number indeed next slide
please
if we look around england what we find
is that
in every area there has been a
relative increase in the
new variant of this virus that is
spreading
around the country fastest increase
in the east of england london and the
south east
but it is now taking off in other areas
as well
in some of the areas where it took off
to the highest level
uh and tier four was brought in during a
period when schools were closed
there may be some early indications of
some leveling off but i think we
shouldn't over interpret that but it is
really clear that this new variant is
has been rising
uh in all parts of the country and what
we've seen
is that the bits of the country which
have got some of the lower rates and had
previously controlled things
particularly
in the northeast and north west for
example the
rate of increase has in many of these
been higher than in some of the southern
areas which have got very high rates
already
next slide please and this is
inevitably translated into new numbers
of patients going into hospital
so these are the number of people in
hospital uh all the way from the first
of april
uh through to the first of january and
you can see the first peak
of people in hospital then decreased due
to the
remarkable efforts of everyone in the
country
during the first lockdown and then
through the summer months
an increase which then again went down
due to
the second lockdown but now really
a very rapid increase and i don't think
you need any modelling to see
in what direction uh the number of
hospitalized
patients with covid is going and this is
going up
very rapidly and of course we are still
in the middle of winter
next slide please and
sadly of course some of those people uh
go on to die
this is the number of deaths that people
had a positive test result
and there was an increase which led to
the second
lockdown a decrease following that
but these numbers of deaths are now
increasing again
they are at this point quite a long way
below the first peak
and there are three reasons for that uh
the first of which which is very good
news
is that doctors nurses medical staff in
general
are able to manage this disease better
than they did previously better drugs
things like dexamethasone
but also better treatment all round
the second reason is that there is uh an
age effect that some of the people who
are being infected the moment are
younger age than in the first
wave but this obviously what we've seen
previously
is it moves up through the age bands
over time
but the third reason is that uh deaths
are much delayed
so what happens is people get infected
there's then a delay before they get ill
enough to go into hospital
and then there's quite a long delay
before some people
sadly die and we will unfortunately see
because of the spike in people going
into hospital
from the last slide we will inevitably
see an increase in number of people with
who die of this disease as we go into
the rest of january thank you very much
thanks chris uh patrick thanks very much
let's go to a question from the public
hannah from northamptonshire
good evening my question is how are you
supporting people with severe mental
health issues
for example my mum suffers from
schizophrenia and doesn't understand
the pandemic circumstances
how would you help someone like her
thank you
well hannah thank you very much uh
for your question and obviously i'm
very sorry for the extra uh anxiety that
the pandemic is causing uh people such
as your
your mom uh people with uh mental health
conditions and i
i totally understand why uh people are
concerned we've put a
a huge amount obviously into uh nhs uh
mental health care i think about another
12 billion or so but directly during the
uh during the pandemic uh what we're
doing now hannah is trying to support
some of the wonderful
mental health care charities uh that
reach out and work with people like your
i like your mom and i think we put about
uh 19 or 20 million
uh into that that's that's what we're
doing at the moment but
you know clearly the best thing for your
mother and everybody is that we get
through this as
as fast as possible thank you hannah
let's go to
unless anybody wants to add anything to
that thank you let's go to
uh to rachel from reading i have two
children at university
one in hall's residence and one in
private accommodation
could you advise how students will be
supported to meet their costs of
accommodation that they are not able to
live in
and could the government advise if there
is any support
to reduce tuition fees or the need to
repay student loans
thank you thanks very much uh
rachel well obviously we will be looking
very carefully at what's happening to
to students as a result of the uh the
fact that their their courses have been
postponed the uh
the the absence of the the tuition that
they would expect
what we hope is that uh they will get uh
online learning that will allow them to
continue with their
degree courses but clearly there are
going to be issues
to do with their the cost of their
accommodation
that we will have to be uh we will have
to look at as a as a government and see
uh what arrangements the uh the
universities are
are making to to to deal with you know
the the reasonable concerns
uh of many many students and i i want to
thank students
uh for the the the sacrifice that you
are making in staying away from
uh university learning online as as uh
you have to
uh like all other students and pupils in
the next uh
few weeks and and months i know it's a
big sacrifice
but uh it i believe sincerely it will be
worth it
uh for the for the reopening of
education and the reopening
uh of our lives thank you very much
rachel let's go to
um uh vicki young of the bbc
prime minister the whole country is
relying on you to take the right steps
at the right time and many think that
you waited too long to bring in
extra restrictions how can i have
confidence in your decision making when
on sunday
you insisted all schools should stay
open
and the very next they ordered them to
close and to professor witty
and professor valance when did you first
advise the government to lock down in
england
and do you think the vaccine rollout
timetable
is realistic uh thanks
very much vicky well i think it's it's
very important to understand that
uh we've been looking at the
new variant uh very hard ever since it
we
first became aware of its its rapid
spread i think on the 18th
of uh of december and uh it's been
it's been clear that the uh the tier
four measures were something that
we wanted to evaluate and over the
course of the
uh the days leading up to sunday clearly
like
everybody else in the country we were we
were hoping
uh that we would start to see some uh
some impact and that uh
we would be able to to keep schools open
because keeping schools open
is an absolute uh priority for for
for this country and keeping kids in
education
is absolutely vital for this for this
country but uh
vicky what we obviously had to to
contend with with
uh figures uh not just the the decision
by the four cmos to
to go up to alert level five but uh
figures for
the infection rate i think of 80 000 one
day then 65 000
uh the next it was clear that
we got to a situation where
tier 4 on its own couldn't be
relied upon to get the virus
under control and that's without uh
really going the whole way
and asking people to stay at home and
and sadly to to close schools as well
and that's why we took the
uh the step that we did uh and i
appreciate the the frustration of
of teachers and and parents uh and
obviously the frustration of pupils but
can i repeat
uh my my thanks i i don't know whether
i'm being premature and saying this
vicki but i believe that the
the bbc uh is coming forward with a
a big program of uh of of education
uh for three hours a day that will be uh
something that the government will be
doing everything
we can to help with remote learning
as well so let's take
half of the second one
the cmos met yesterday
morning and review the data which had
been getting steadily worse in all four
nations of
the uk and they advised that we should
move to
level five yesterday uh patrick might
want to talk about sage advice
uh independently of that in terms of the
vaccine timetable my view is that the
vaccine timetable is realistic
but not easy and the nhs is going to you
have to use
multiple channels to get this out but
they are very determined to do this
but that does not make it easy and of
course in the case of the pfizer vaccine
as i think is widely
reported it's more difficult to handle
because of the complicated
cold chain model and we also with both
vaccines
wanted to be very careful in the first
two or three days that we uh we went a
little bit slowly just in case there
were some initial uh unexpected problems
but i think we do now have a situation
where things can be
rolled out across lots of different
channels and
i think what is really important is that
we do that according to
the ordering which has been recommended
by the jcvi which the joint commission
vaccination immunization which the prime
minister talked about
and the reason for that is that that
ordering has that means that we will
have the maximum
impact on the disease because the people
that by far the highest
risk of dying will be vaccinated first
and those who care for them
then the next uh down including nhs
workers
social care workers and then on down all
the way through to people in their 50s
and those under 50
who have other underlying health
problems by doing it in that way
at whatever speed we do the uh the
mortality benefits will be front loaded
and what we'll first
see is a reduction in mortality over
time
and then after that there will be a a
slowing of the
pressure of kobit on the nhs but that
will take longer so those two
will not happen at the same rate and the
final thing to do is to say that
in the uk we've taken a decision based
on jcbi advice
but endorsed by uh scientific bodies
like
uh the site for immunology endorsed by
uh other medical bodies like the royal
college of general practitioners
to delay the first dose
of both vaccines by 12 weeks and we've
done this based on a number of different
scientific
lines of decision making and that is to
allow us
to maximize over the first 12 weeks the
number of people who can be vaccinated
so we can get down those jcvi levels as
fast as possible before the second
vaccine is given
and that you know that should provide a
high degree not the complete protection
because everybody should have their
second
uh dose at 12 weeks but that should
provide a high degree
of protection uh and get us through that
as fast as we can
because we are facing as i think the
prime minister said and the data shows
a really serious emergency at the moment
the increased transmissibility of the
new variant
was clearly a concern and given the
effects of um restrictions it was
obvious that actually
you need to do more in order to retain
it if you've got a higher degree of
transmissibility
so um i think the view from sage and the
papers are there was that it was
likely that more measures would be
needed to retain
a transmission of a variant that had an
intrinsically higher transmissibility
rate
and that's indeed what's what's now born
out that you see very fast growth very
fast spread amongst
all age groups and it's going to need
really much firmer measures in order to
keep on top of this
thanks very much uh vicki let's go to
robert peston of itv
um gentlemen and given that there are
now a million people
infected what is the chance that we'll
be out of lock down
before the middle end march possibly
even
later um and secondly to
the scientists in particular you'll be
aware that some of your colleagues
are concerned that by widening the gap
between first and second dose you are
increasing the risk
of the virus mutating and building up
resistance to the vaccine could you
quantify that risk for us please
uh thanks rob let me let me go have a
look at the the first one
uh first and i think you know it all
depends the
our ability to uh come out of the
the lockdown measures our ability to uh
get through this
uh fast depends uh on an on a number of
things and
obviously if provided we don't uh learn
anything new about the virus that we
don't yet understand so
there's not some new mutation that we
haven't uh currently
uh bargained for provided the the
vaccine
rollout goes according to plan uh
provided um the vaccine is as
efficacious as we
uh as we think it is um but you know
above all provided that everybody
follows the uh the guidance now
everybody sticks to the uh to the
measures that we have
uh now then we think that by
the middle of february uh when
a very considerable portion of the most
vulnerable groups
will have been uh vaccinated or so we
open
uh believe that's the uh the top uh four
of the jcvi
uh cohorts then you know there really is
the prospect
of um uh of beginning the relaxation
of some of these measures i wouldn't put
it any stronger
than that but you'll also appreciate
that uh there are lots of
caveats lots of ifs uh built into that
the most important of which
is uh that we all now follow the
guidance and
uh and stay at home let the nhs save
lives
i'll first go this but patrick want to
add to this on the vaccine
question um by extending the gap
we are going to over the next uh three
months be able to essentially double the
number of people who can be vaccinated
so if by process of not very difficult
mathematics if over that period
uh there is more than fifty percent
protection
then you've actually won more people
will
overall have been protected than would
have been otherwise and our
quite strong view is that uh we think it
will be protection will be quite a lot
more than 50
so therefore in net public health terms
there'll be substantially more
protection by going faster
not with the absolutely complete
protection we fully agree we need a
second
uh dose for everybody but with the great
majority of
the protection for that initial period
so we get twice as many people
vaccinated over that period and then we
catch up as we go into spring
there are obviously some um unknowns in
that
and there's quite a vigorous scientific
debate about some of those unknowns
and one of the things people have raised
is a theoretical risk
that by having this longer gap uh you
could actually lead to
a slightly increased risk of an escape
mutant and that is a
a real worry but quite a small little
worry within the system i think
we discussed this and patrick may want
to add to this among scientists involved
in sage and others
and i think the general view was the
size of the increase in risk is
sufficiently small but measured against
its ability to double the number of
people who actually are vaccinated
the public health arguments are really
strongly for doing what we decided to do
and that's why
jcbi independently mhra were content
with us taking this approach
and a variety of other bodies have
agreed that this is a sensible balance
of risk
approval clearly if we had infinite
vaccine we might have taken different
approaches but we don't
at this point in time for the next uh
three to four months
the number of vaccines we have available
is going to constrain
our ability to get through the 25 to 30
million people we must do to get through
all of the jcbi
areas and whilst this is such a
fast-moving
virus at this point in time our view was
very strongly on balance of risk
the benefits to the uk for us at this
point of the epidemic
uh were in favor of doing this patrick
may want to add to that well
the only thing to add is is the more you
vaccinate the more you put evolutionary
pressure on the virus
so it's true that as you get up to very
high levels of vaccination that the
virus is then struggling to find out
what to do and that
eventually will become an issue and and
the va
and the virus body will mutate at that
point and that means that different
vaccines will be needed in due course
and one of the
i think very exciting things about the
science behind this is the
messenger rna vaccines in particular are
incredibly fast to make in response to
new mutations so that in due course in
years to come as we think about this
that will be something that
that i think gives an advantage to being
able to get around it but
all vaccination will ultimately put some
pressure on viruses to mutate
thanks very much uh sam coats of sky
there are 60 000 new infections recorded
today partly driven by
kids spreading this new strain more
readily parents want realism
can you look parents in the eye and tell
them that all kids will
definitely be back in the classroom
before the summer holidays
so patrick valance we've heard quite a
lot recently about a second new variant
this is the one from south africa
has it reached our shores and how
worried should we be about the south
african variant of coronavirus being
resistant to the vaccine
and professor chris witte how normal can
life really be
after just the 13.2 million most
vulnerable alone
have been vaccinated isn't the risk for
those age 20
up to 50 too high to let it rip through
those
age groups uh well sam i'll i'll take
the the first one of those excellent
uh questions uh just on uh whether
we can be absolutely sure that uh that
schools will
uh will reopen well i i just go back to
the answer really i gave to
to robert uh person we think
that with the vaccination program we can
do a huge amount to
uh take out of the path of the virus
those who are
uh most vulnerable that clearly offers
opportunities
uh to uh our country uh to
to do things differently uh to approach
the
uh the whole issue of non-pharmaceutical
interventions
very differently so i'm you know i i'm
i'm full of
the same optimism uh and fundamental
hope about the
the position that uh that i think chris
has uh adopted
uh uh and that i think that things
really will be very different
uh by the spring and that is what i
would certainly say to every parent
in the land so on the question of the
variance
um as a virus replicates you get changes
in the genetic code as
new variant new mutations come in and
things change and
and those changes in the genetic code
then lead to changes sometimes in parts
of the protein
and that may lead to shape changes or
charge changes on the protein
that might mean that the virus becomes
recognized differently by the immune
system and that's really the
the concern that people are looking at
if i take the uk variant
um what we know is that those changes
and there was
22 changes in in in the genetic code
um made the virus more transmissible as
far as we can see
it doesn't make it um hidden from the
immune system
so if you've had an infection before
actually the evidence is you probably
neutralize
um this virus as well and the
expectation is the same would be for
vaccine with the south africa variant
there's another change
that change is theoretically a bit more
substantial in terms of the
shape if you like so it has a bit more
of an effect potentially on the shape of
the
of the um viral protein
which theoretically gives it a bit more
risk of not being recognized
but there's nothing again yet to suggest
that's the case so this is being looked
at
very actively and it's worth remembering
that when a when a
vaccine is given you don't just make one
antibody against one bit you make lots
of antibodies against lots of different
bits
and so it's very unlikely that
all of that would be escaped by any
mutation it's more likely
that if there's an effect it's a sort of
minor effect to decrease the
binding or decrease the efficacy of the
vaccine but we don't know yet for the
south africa that needs to be looked at
but it's a theoretical risk and every
time we see a variant that's going to be
the
the question that comes up but it needs
to be looked at but at the moment you'd
say that the most likely thing is that
this
wouldn't abolish vaccine effect it may
have some um if
uh overall effect and efficacy but we
don't know
and on the question you asked me um if
we did not
do the things all of us must now do if
people don't take
the stay at home seriously the risk at
this point in time
in the middle of winter with this new
variant is extraordinarily high
what is going to happen over time is the
risk level is gradually going to
decrease it's not going to be
it's it's really bad and then suddenly
it stops it's that we're going to
essentially have the risk walking down a
path
things will be able to be lifted by
degrees possibly at different rates in
different parts of the country we'll
have to see
and the government has made very clear
that ministers prioritize education for
example is one of the things that would
go
early but that's a ministerial decision
very much but the things we lifted stage
by stage
and will then get over time to a point
where people say this level of risk is
one that society is prepared to tolerate
and lift you know right down to almost
no
restrictions at all we might have to
bring a few in uh in the next winter for
example that is possible
because winter will benefit the virus
but the aim of this is to de-risk it as
much as possible
by the vaccine to the point where
actually we get to the stage
where the risk is incredibly low
relative to where we are now
and we just say just as we do with flu
where every year
roughly on an average year about 7 000
people a year die in
a bad year up to 20 000 people a year
die we accept there is a level of risk
that society
will tolerate and we have we should
tolerate
people die that's one of the things that
happens and we have to do that
at a certain point but that's a
political decision that's a societal
decision
what we can do though with the vaccine
is take the risk down and down initially
with the mortality
then the big pressure on the nhs then
the risk of people actually having
uh infections which could lead to things
like long covid
because younger people can still have
really serious problems with this
and those risks but little by little be
reduced by vaccination
but zero risk is not something which is
a realistic possibility and this will
not happen in a single bound it'll
happen
by degrees thanks very much uh
chris uh thanks sam let's go to jason
graves dailymail
thanks um prime minister you've
committed i think to vaccinate
uh 13 million people in the next six
weeks that means uh something like two
million people a week
what what needs to happen to getters
to that figure um
you know what what what changes need to
be made because we know we're near there
at the moment
and and i think you said we'd get daily
updates for numbers can i just check is
that
uh a commitment to publish a daily
figure for how many people
have been vaccinated and professor witty
can i ask you
quickly is this locked down enough
to reverse uh the spread of this virus
or are we in a kind of race against time
now and
and you said we might need a few
measures next winter still
what sort of majors are you talking
about thanks
very very much jason and look on your uh
very very important questions about the
the pace of the vaccine well that you're
absolutely right
actually i think the numbers uh for the
first four
uh uh jcvi uh
groups uh might be a little bit north of
a little bit higher than 13
million but we're going to we're going
to do them as fast as we possibly can
we've set the target as you know by the
middle of uh by
the middle of february yes it is a huge
effort it'll be this is the biggest
vaccination uh program in the history of
this country
and this country is already i think uh
done more than any
uh certainly not more than any other
european uh country
um what it will require
is a lot of people working uh together
and
uh the the nhs uh the
uh the armed services uh
every aspect of government is is working
at this absolutely
uh absolutely flat out the the the
the rate limiting the factor at the
moment
is uh making sure that we uh can get
enough uh a vaccine uh where we want it
fast enough and one of the problems as
you know is that uh the astrazeneca
uh vaccine which has just come on stream
needs to be properly um batch tested
properly approved before it can be put
into into people's arms
and this is a just a process that that
takes time
to do but we will be ratcheting uh
it up over the next uh days and weeks
ahead in the way that
in the way that you describe and we'll
be giving more details on thursday
of where we've got to i've given the
figures uh today
and what we'll be trying to do jason is
to try to
and then daily from monday and what
we'll be trying to do is to try to break
down
some of these figures for people so
everybody can see
uh which groups are getting the the
vaccine and how it's
how it's being distributed across the
country because i i
my feeling is this is something of
massive national
interest and we've really got to be as
transparent
as we've as we can possibly be you ask
me the lockdown will be enough i think
the key
to this is all of us buying into this
really seriously
if we all buy into this people stay at
home if people fix apart from the things
which are
like work uh going out for essential
shopping uh
exercise if people um stick to those
rules
really strongly and at the same time
the nhs is vaccinating as fast as it can
then our hope is the lockdown will be
enough but
we've all got to do that this is very
much got to be a collective effort no
one can do this
on their own you can't just do it by
rules it's got to be people
buying into this really seriously in
terms of
longer term things obviously what we all
hope is that we can get a vaccine
program that actually means we don't
need anything
in the future at any stage that would be
the ideal but i think it's also
important to understand that this
coronavirus is not going to go away
just as flu doesn't go away just as many
other viruses don't go away
and the time that benefits the most is
always winter that's one of the reasons
we're having problems now along with the
new variant
and therefore we just need to keep an
open mind about that the hope would be
we don't need to do anything
certainly nothing on the scale we're
having to do at the moment because
vaccination
should take the great majority possibly
all of the heavy lifting
but i think what we shouldn't kid
ourselves is it just disappears with
spring
what will happen with spring is the risk
go right down hopefully we'll have
spring summer and autumn
possibly winter as well uh with with
almost nothing in place
uh once we've the full vaccination
program is full
it's through but we just need to be
aware of the fact this is not a problem
that just disappears
thanks very much jason uh let's go to
andy woodcock independent
um prime minister we understand that um
the uk is shortly going to introduce
mandatory negative coronavirus tests for
foreign nationals flying to the country
um tests are something that airports
have been asking for for months they've
been
used in uh successfully in other
countries for a very long time now
why has it taken so long for britain to
to adopt this position
is that something that has um has uh
contributed towards and coronavirus
being so persistent here in the uk
and um if if that's what we're
requesting from foreign nationals why
not uk nationals coming from abroad too
and also if i could ask the scientist
that the prime minister has described
schools as a potential vector for
coronavirus
if that's the case why is it that
teachers and pupils are not on the
priority list for vaccination
if we vaccinate them is that not
something which would allow us to open
schools sooner
well thanks andy first of all on on um
i'll ask christmas battery to answer
about
about transmission in in schools um did
i just repeat that schools are
safe um uh but on
on what we're doing to uh protect the uk
from transmission from abroad we will be
bringing in
uh measures to um uh
to ensure that we uh that we test people
coming
uh into this country and make and uh and
prevent the virus from being
uh re-readmitted um but uh
patrick or christian won't add anything
on them
on school but two two points on this uh
the first thing is just to restrict the
point the prime minister
made one thing that we do not think is
that this new variant is any more
dangerous for children than the old
variant is
uh and there's no evidence for example
the hospitals are filling up with
children
there is always a risk with any
infection to uh people of all ages
but children are relatively much less
affected than other areas
than other groups which is one of the
few good things you can say
about coronavirus and that will be
important when obviously when uh
schools can go back uh in terms of
vaccination priority
i think from a clinical point of view
the real priority is to make sure that
we i
you know we know who the people are who
are by far the most likely to die
and are by far the most likely to end up
in hospital and that is that ordering
which the joint committee on vaccination
immunization jcvi has
put in place and which everybody who's
looked at this has agreed this is
correct ordering lots of academics lots
of others have looked at it and they all
agree
so i think it's very important that that
ordering which takes us down not just to
the first four tiers which the prime
minister talked about but all the way
down to people
who are in their 50s which would include
some teachers obviously
and people who've got uh underlying
health conditions is followed through
because those are the people who are the
most likely to come at risk
then that still leaves around half of
the well slightly more than actually
than half of the population
and there will have to be some decisions
made about that in due course but we are
some
way from that and i think the key thing
is prioritize those who are most likely
to come to clinical harm a final point
on the vaccine is not neither of the
vaccines are currently licensed using
children so we would not be going down
that path
at this stage uh but uh that may
obviously
change over time patrick do you want to
add to that
terrific thanks uh andy let's go to
dominic of metro
hi there prime minister uh the uk have
seen more than 50 000
people test positive for uh coronavirus
for eight days in a row now
uh if you had taken this lockdown
decision 24 hours earlier
it would have stopped three million
primary school children mixing for a day
and taking a new wave of infection back
to their families
do you regret this delay and secondly if
i may
nearly 1 million children access the
internet via mobile
phone connections where a day's lessons
can cost
100 pounds on pay-as-you-go you still
insist that
schools are safe shouldn't those
children be in school
and if not why are telecom companies
allowed to charge for access
to school and educational websites still
yeah well i mean in a way andy i think
you uh
sorry dominic you've you've answered
forgive me uh you've answered the
uh the your your question about why did
we want to
to keep schools open uh it's just such
an imperative for
any country and and any society and i've
as i said i think to
uh to to vicky uh from the bbc uh
we want to we wanted to do everything we
could to uh
make that possible uh alas on uh
yesterday
it became clear that the the data simply
wasn't going to
uh support that and the the risk was
that the
uh the the tiering system uh the tier
four system
uh without uh taking schools out of the
uh equation was just not going to be
enough on its own we couldn't take that
risk and
although we're now seeing some signs uh
that maybe tier four is is starting to
uh to work in uh in london and maybe a
bit in the southeast on
on the new variant the spread of the new
variant was was really
uh very very troubling uh indeed so
that's why we took the
uh the action that we did we don't want
to do it we want to support
uh kids in uh school if we possibly can
i'm glad that the bbc is uh
is um as i say uh putting a lot of
educational stuff
uh on on tv that that is fantastic uh
we're also looking at
the very point that you make about uh
the the potential cost to parents of of
online
teaching and we're gonna uh do our best
to support them in any way that we can
and to and to work with the
uh the uh the internet uh companies to
uh to see what we can do to to help
because this unquestionably will be
a a a tough period and
all i can say is what we want to do is
get back to a position as fast as
possible where we can get kids back
in school uh and that's why
uh we're we're doing all the things that
we're we're doing now
thanks very much everybody um i i
appreciate that this is
a very very tough final stretch uh for
uh this country it's been made tougher
by the new variant much tougher
uh by the by the new variant but the
jabs are going in
uh to people's arms day by day we'll
keep you
updated on what is going on and in the
meantime i must repeat the
basic message uh what we've got to do is
to stay at home protect
the nhs and save lives thanks everybody
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and